all right so welcome back to the last
session of the day we're very happy to
have
you
she started
into like uh
share data services
and you should also check out
so much and thank you for being here
so um i wanted to explain the title here
because
i i think baited you in into coming here
by telling you that we're going to
repurpose computation non-strategic
computation for strategic
computation
no purposes
and
one of the things i was thinking is that
really a better title and one that's
more appropriate for this week for this
talk is really thinking about beyond
worst case adversaries because you know
this is this is the week about
sequential decision makings in all forms
from strategic to adversarial
and we are going to think about them and
really think about both statistical and
computational challenges the focus of
the talk is what it was before just
wanted to make sure the title is
something that you can you can see the
connection immediately with what you're
going to be talking about
so
the idea is how are we going to think
about batch optimization and learning
after a week of having thought about
sequential decision making
okay so we are quite used to thinking
about optimization happening in batch
because it's actually something that we
have decades of work and
decades of machine learning has been
built upon that idea
so what is the main idea here the idea
is that
one of the questions we want to answer
in learning theory is that
what are the concepts that can be
learned from data
and how many observations
and data usually comes in the batch
format the data sets that we have we
have something z1 to zm
then we put it into some optimization
that optimization
routine will try to find a function
maybe from a sort of prefix set of
functions that fits the data as best as
possible
and then it will spread out the function
and i'll take that function and forever
in the future we'll use this function
for any other prediction i want to do
and really the idea behind why
this makes sense in what world we should
actually think about machine learning as
this kind of a pipeline is that
the data which is this data that we are
trying to learn from that data itself is
generated from a distribution and this
distribution is remaining the same
so we have really a nice world another
way to put it an iid world and that's
why
we for decades we have tried to
understand how we can get a data set
optimize something over it or learn
something for
it and this is really ubiquitous on to
optimization and learning and prediction
in general
um
some of you might be more
comfortable thinking about binary
classification
for example of
perhaps physical or abstract objects for
example
uh knowing whether pictures of chairs
and tables is telling them apart
or given
uh spams or emails being able to say if
an email is a spam or not or given a
review knowing if it's fake or not so
those are binary prediction tasks that
fall in here if we think about the data
as remaining stationary
or you might be more comfortable
thinking about general sort of best fit
type regression functions so you might
be more comfortable thinking about i
want to be able to predict
the demand or i want to be able to
learn or predict how to set reserve
prices
these are all prediction tasks and as
long as we think the world is
a stochastic world where data sets are
generated iid we have used this formula
of taking a data set optimizing
something over it
um
to to essentially learn and optimize
now what's happened and why
we have heard so much about sequential
decision making and
learning is that
that assumption that the world remains
stationary and nice and iid
is less and less the case
the more these algorithms actually enter
the practical domain because learning
algorithms and environments are
interacting and they are interacting in
many different ways that makes the data
evolve
sometimes the data is just evolving
because the environment is evolving in
unpredictable ways or unpredictable
sort of um
for unpredictable reasons that we cannot
account for
that that could be something like a
stock market
but also a lot of times it's evolving
because of some adversarial manipulation
other strategic manipulations
for example uh sometimes content um like
in youtube um content
or your
spam box you know uh the content is
created to pass through a filter and you
might keep changing this filter but
people who are generating this content
also want to get around the filter and
get the spam into your mailbox or get
the video uh to pass through the quality
control and be posted so those are some
adversarial manipulations there also
brought the other strategic
manipulations that i'm not going to
focus too much about but i think it's
important to still note for example
things that aren't super malicious but
they're still
somebody changing their data because of
the benefit that it has for them like in
uber or lyft you might um if you're
looking for a ride you might change the
location of where you're requesting the
ride or if you're a driver you might
sort of decline some of the rides in the
hope of getting better
better deal out of it
but importantly the sequential nature of
these
problems is the reason we want to study
sequential decision making
and i also want to study sequential
decision making
and the way i'm going to view sequential
decision making is very similar to what
you've seen already a lot in this
semester but i wanted to
still establish this common perspective
in case you just need a refresher so
this is sequential as being perceived as
being adversarial model of online
learning or online optimization with
full information
so one way to think about this is that i
have key interactions with um between a
learner and the world and the world is
an adaptive adversary
the learner at every round picks some
kind of a function this could be the
prediction function if you want to think
about sort of the binary classification
and then the environment will uh react
to it and usually select some
adversarial like adversarially chosen
instance and shows it the learner gets a
loss and then also gets to see what was
chosen by the adversary
and the idea is that we want to get a
regret
that is vanishing and the average we get
being vanishing means that the gap
between what my algorithm achieved over
t time steps on average is getting
not much worse than the best possible
function in hindsight would have
achieved
and
we know that
essentially like this this is kind of
saying that
my benchmark is still the batch
benchmark if the data had appeared i
could have sort of still applied all
that black box and what we saw on the
first slide here
but the data didn't appear this way and
i still want to be able to pretend as if
as if i'm doing as well as i could have
done if it was a batch data
and by now we know that these problems
can be solved especially in full
information setting
we actually understand them really well
for decades we have been under being
able to understand them
um
we know that when the function class is
finite you can get square root of log of
h over t
and this is a
celebrated result of rowing and shapiri
and also when the class is not finite uh
this optimal achievable regret is
defined by something called the little
zone dimension
and this was a result of
ben devitol and um shell shorts
it doesn't really matter what this
little sun dimension is i just want to
put it here
throughout the talk i'm not really going
to talk about it whenever it matters
i'll actually tell you how to think
about it but more importantly we know
how to solve these problems
but the algorithms all of these
algorithms that can solve this type of
problem
importantly
are not computationally efficient
they're in fact nothing like their batch
perspective it's it's not that black box
i don't just try to optimize something
that looks good historically i have to
redesign these algorithms and the design
of them tends to be computationally
inefficient and have really bad overhead
so
what we really want to do in this talk
is not to design things from scratch
instead try to repurpose whatever
insights we've gained from batch
optimization
and then import them to sequential
optimization
essentially we're going to assume that
that erm oracle the black box that we
had here is really a black box
and i am going to try to
get that black black box i'm going to
call it an erm oracle
and only using that black box
gets sequential optimization no regret
algorithms
okay
so this is called an oracle efficient
online learning
and there are many reasons we would want
these types of algorithms
the first reason is that
as i said previous algorithms overall
were inefficient
how inefficient typically they needed to
keep track of the performance of each
function that was available to the
learner
and these functions tend to be
exponential like let me give you an
example of this we were talking about
potentially setting reserve prices
as an application of online learning
so if i have many items if i'm trying to
set their prices reserve prices all
independently
then
the number of
functions that i have is exponential in
the number of items
even if i could just like set their
prices to be like high or low
another way to think about this is if i
was dealing with binary classification
um i might have only k different
features that i care about
but even knowing what each of these
features should be high or low again i
have at least two decay number of
functions to worry about
so we really don't want to explicitly
think about number of functions or
functions available to to the learner
instead we want to be able to use these
erm oracles to access those functions
so this is really the first reason the
fact that those algorithms were
computationally inefficient
now
it's only useful this perspective
if
my batch optimization that erm oracle is
actually either theoretically or
practically more efficient
because otherwise why am i going to use
that
and this is typically the case both in
theory and practice or at least in one
of them
so usually when it is the case in theory
it's because the
the format of batch optimization was
itself very nice and lent itself to
polynomial time computation
this is the case for example if you
could solve the problem with a linear
program or with a number of other things
we know how to optimize um
probably with computational efficient
algorithms
but even if actually we don't have those
types of algorithms what's happened is
that
because we've really cared about batch
optimization
for
decades
we have
developed really good tools for doing
that even when theory sort of fell short
of doing it
so one example of this is that integer
programming uh program solving problem
softwares have got really really good
over the years so you can solve integer
programs occasionally like really fast
and really well
but
even though they are not technically
speaking computationally efficient
algorithms
so this is another reason to want to be
able to reduce your problem to something
that can be solved with these existing
batch optimization
lastly i think this is a bit of a
philosophical question too
um
what we started this whole talk was that
the world is changing
and it's becoming more strategic it's
becoming more
interactive sometimes for economic
reasons sometimes for other reasons just
unpredictable evolution of data
so what we are asking here is that
how much do we need to actually
completely redo all of our insights
completely redo all of our intuition and
tools to adjust to this new world
if
new
insights or completely like new insight
that needs to be built from scratch are
not needed we can then reserve our
energy to really think about those
problems that need to be addressed from
scratch
so
this is important to know
how different is computation for
strategic agents versus computation for
agents that are not necessarily
strategic they're more sort of
predictable coming from some
distributions
so these are three reasons for
which we should really be asking if
oracle efficient online algorithms exist
or not
okay let me take a second to make sure
you have a chance to ask any questions
you might have
any questions kind of
whether technically so far or
philosophically
or about where we are going to be headed
yes
every time when you uh at every time
step you're going to treat that
that's a great question so what you're
asking is that assume i have a batch
optimization oracle how are you going to
use it
i have dedicated my next slide to
actually talking about some uh
naive to not so naive ways of using it
so i'll come to that in a minute and
then i'll come back to you to see if
that makes sense
so far everything has been quite
abstract because we haven't actually
started looking at these in depth yes
will we factor in like the size of the
problems
that's a great question so what i put in
this green box is very handy
what does it mean to just get a batch
optimization and then efficiently solve
a no regret algorithm a couple things go
into this so
i'm not going to go too much into depth
but let me just tell you
things you can do is call an oracle a
polynomial many times
what happens i'll give you recipes that
essentially you're only calling an
oracle once per time step or twice per
time step no more than that so you don't
need to worry about it
the second aspect is the amount of
effort you need to put into calling this
oracle which is how much input am i
creating for it
also has to be polynomial in the number
of time steps in
parameters of interest essentially so
you shouldn't do exponential amount of
work
and then call an oracle or you should
then create infinitely large data set
and then call an oracle on that so those
are essentially the two ways to think
about it
good news is as i said we'll only call
it once or twice per round and
the data sets we create are
very obviously going to be bounded in
size and in a nice space
other questions
just like
each time step that's a good question um
the question is is it necessary to call
an oracle once per round or can i call
it even less than that
um
logarithmic i believe is not enough
you could call it
square root i believe like polynomial
but smaller than that but you're not
going to worry about it essentially
the running time
wise i'm not trying to optimize this
much
i do care a lot about what regret i get
about this but if you want to call it
once per round i'm happy
um with that
but that's a really good quick question
like
how how much can you like push this
do you want to work under
the same oracle at all times or yeah
yeah we think the oracle as a black box
so we don't actually ever use anything
about it other than the fact that
it has the ability to do some like
optimize over whatever it could give us
i'll formalize that also the next one
other questions
okay
so
there was a really good question which
was um
how do you even use these erm oracles
and this is a type of exercise that you
might repeat a couple times during the
talk today which is
um we'll talk about things that might
appear very nice um
and then try to make them more and more
reasonable so
let's let's you're gonna see the first
example of this here so first of all
what is an oracle just just in case it
wasn't clear so far an oracle is
something that can do this type of
computation
it can take a data set s
and it knows some loss function is
trying to minimize and then it finds the
function whose cumulative loss is as
little as possible
now
kind of to just make this a little bit
easier i think it's best to think about
binary classification so this loss is
just going to be
an error that you might make on an
instance
and uh
the
instance z itself is um
a feature
vector and a label
uh feature vector could be like an image
of a cat or dog or chair or table and
whether or not it was one of those
things
so what you're going to do is to think
about a number of ways you might want to
call an oracle
what is one way of calling an oracle
pair round
what should that be the input of
one
it
doesn't have to be a good suggestion as
i said we are going to start naive
running on the data so far
on the data so far that's actually the
second most naive solution because the
most naive solution is the one that none
of you would probably want to say it out
loud but i want to put it out here which
is the thing that's impossible to do
if i knew the future
maybe i could have just run it on the
future
okay
why
none of you wanted to say it it's
because it's impossible this is way too
much wishful thinking
but
this is right the second thing that we
could do
is to call it on what you've seen so far
that's that's actually quite reasonable
um
anyone wants to argue why this is not a
very good idea
in presence of an adversary
you can suffer
it's not suffering
right what happens here is that for one
thing this is a deterministic type of
algorithm and whenever you're dealing
with an adversary it's a bad idea being
deterministic because they can make sure
that you pay the next like they know
what you're gonna do and then they can
make you pay for it
so this is also a bad idea because while
it's doable it's uh has a large
perspective okay now that we know that
these are bad ideas uh what is one step
that's slightly better than this in
particular i said we need to avoid
determinism any suggestions
right so
the next suggestion is well i have the
past data
let me attend to that some random stuff
and what those random stuff are i don't
know right now this is something to be
discussed later but nevertheless i'm
just going to sort of add some things
and this is okay
um this is in fact one of two ways of
doing this type of
adding data
another way of thinking about
hallucinating some future data
and a lot more subtle why you could use
something that looks like this is that
instead of learning a function
you could
think about just directly making a
prediction about the function
about that instance
so one way to do that is that you have
your past you have your future and you
have the instance you were asked to make
a new prediction on
and then you say well
how would have my erm done if i
predicted plus on it versus i predicted
minus on it and that kind of tells you
the sensitivity of how important it is
to predict plus or minus
so you could kind of use the gap between
the two
to decide with what probability you
should be predicting one and
what probability you should be
predicting minus one okay
this is just two different ways
of using these
future
data points that aren't necessarily
future but something that you randomly
guessed
that was a question here
could it matter
so like report settings uh using the
sign of this gap or the actual
size of the vm
um
when this okay when
when this loss is not a binary loss
necessarily it's real value things get a
little bit hairy so if you're interested
in that i will tell you to like read
more and i'll give psychicians here
so you mentioned that the you know just
using all the past data
deterministically has large regret in
part because of the determinism
are there ways to introduce
randomness and not need to hallucinate
future data like some something
something bootstrap something something
there are some ways we're not going to
be talking about them because they don't
probably work for oracle efficiency for
large function classes you can spin your
history but for
this approach has been used in some
online algorithm design especially when
you want to like preserve sparsity or
some specific property of history
but we won't be talking about that
okay
so let me just assign name to this this
second the third second and third
approach this is optimization over past
and a hallucinated future hallucinated
because there's no reason these sis that
you are sort of cooking up have anything
to do with it
and these two lines of work the first
one is the follow the protruder style of
uh argument and algorithm design
introduced by halai van paula
has a long history of being used in many
different settings the second one has
different names but um one popular name
for it it's relaxed and randomized
um has been used introduced by rocklin
sridharan and chamir and again has
been also used in many many different
settings both of them
um together i think have revolutionized
what you think about sequentials
okay so by now
there should be one obvious question in
your mind
which is that i'm talking about
hallucinations but what are these
hallucinations so this is what you're
wondering and if you're wondering how to
hallucinate
it uses no substances unnecessary and we
will talk about this essentially there
are technical points we'll talk about
not at mathematical depth but briefly
which is how what is this distribution
you should be sampling from um what if
if i don't know the future why does it
matter if i can hallucinate it if it
doesn't look like the future
and if i know something about the future
then how is this any better
okay now let me tell you a little bit
about what is known so
there is the worst case regime and
beyond worst case regime in worst case
regime there is uh
there is unfortunately a gap as in what
is statistically achievable in regret is
not computationally achievable
so even if i give you an oracle you
cannot
get a nor good algorithm whenever that
oracle was working for the stochastic
setting
but there are sort of slivers of hope
for certain classes like if the loss is
linear
if it has small domain or if it's
structured in other ways we kind of know
how to get these oracle efficient
results okay
now the interesting thing here is that
the picture is very different when you
go beyond worst case and we'll talk
about what the beyond worst case world
looks like
importantly there is no significant gap
between what is statistically achievable
and what you can achieve with oracle
efficiency okay
both of them are going to be defined by
something called the vc dimension and
the time step and something is which is
about what is the worst beyond worst
case um
type of an adversary like
how much better than worst case you are
this dependence is not the same
um but it's it's
interesting that there is no significant
gap between the two
um there is a concurrent work that also
gets this type of result the regrets
doesn't quite match ours but you can
still think about both of these work as
really thinking about collapsing this
hierarchy and showing that there is no
gap
but the good thing about here is that
when your regret is really nice like the
type of regret we can get not only you
say something for beyond worst case
adversaries actually you get to imply
thanks even for worst-case adversaries
under some functional assumptions like
if the domain was more small or some
other knowledge was there
for this talk i'm going to focus here
only and really tell you a little bit
about
what is a model of beyond worst case
adversary what is one statistical tool
that helps us in getting statistically
optimal regret
and at a high level how does it help us
with the computational aspect
okay so on to what is a smooth um what
is beyond worst case adversary and here
we are going to take the perspective of
smooth analysis if you're familiar with
that perspective
if not i'm going to introduce it
you essentially have a function classes
everything is as before you have a
learner and you have a world the only
thing that changed is that the world is
not fully adversarial the data is
generated from a distribution dt the
adversary is only setting this
distribution dt per round
and this distribution dt is sigma smooth
what is sigma smooth it's a distribution
whose max density
is upper bounded
by some
some one over sigma times the density of
the uniform distribution
um you can vary this sigma if sigma was
zero you don't have any smoothness it
could be fully adversarial because there
is no upper bound if sigma was some
number then essentially you're getting
the adversity to move closer and closer
and closer to the uniform distribution
you still are interested in the same
definition of regret
what your algorithm gets versus what the
best function would have gotten
another way to think about this is that
the world and an adversary or adversary
and nature are working together to
create an instance the adversary picks
one and then sort of the world adds some
noise to it and then we get
so this is smooth analysis
and why do we actually care about smooth
analysis is because
sometimes there's a really big gap
between what's adversarially achievable
and what's
sarcastically achievable and whenever
there is a big gap smooth analysis tells
you which one of the twins is more
realistic
and i'm going to show you why there is a
big gap in online sequential decision
making and we'll do this really quickly
because i know most of you have seen
this
well for those of you who haven't we are
playing a binary search game essentially
there's a threshold beyond it there is a
positive
below it everything is negative
and i'm asking you to label points me
i'm the adversary you're the one who has
to design the algorithm and i'll ask you
to label like point half
and sort of no matter what you say if
you say is positive or negative i'm
gonna disagree with you and i tell you
that you made a mistake and then i'm
going to continue this asking you for a
quarter or three quarter if i was on the
other side and we'll continue playing
this game you'll say something i'll
disagree with you and we'll continue
until the end of time
because there is no end of time we can
continue this infinitely deep
and what happens is here that there
would have been a function that would
have been perfect on whatever the
adversary claimed to be true
but the algorithm made a mistake at
every round
so this is why sequential decision
making
has is not possible if your function
class is is infinitely large it's not
possible to get a nervous algorithm
so you should really think about this as
having this type of a tree that is
creating a problem for you
now
this is telling you that being dealing
with an adaptive adversary is impossible
so the question is then why did the
fully stochastic setting work we all
know that stochasticity and learning
work well together
and really the idea here is that there
is something defined by net that i can
set the granularity of my problem rather
than looking at infinite function
classes i can sort of put a grid on them
and not consider all functions only
consider some of them
what does this look like if this was a
distribution
and uh of the instances that were
stochastically arriving
i could only consider functions like
just think about functions at a one
epsilon at a epsilon granularity this
epsilon being the amount of distribution
under my
curve and then each function is pretty
close to its proxy
what that means is that
no
distribution can concentrate too many of
its points into any of these gaps
because these gaps are by definition
small part of the distribution
and this anti-concentration is the
reason we can learn in stochastic
settings
and it's exactly the lack of this
anti-concentration
that becomes a problem
i cannot define a net until the game is
finished
because the final net is the one that is
being made in the future steps and the
adversary can decide where to focus as
points and therefore create this net
keep changing sort of what i think about
what the net is going to be
so what could have helped in this
scenario
well as i said we're going to start by
naive things that look like wishful
thinkings and then get to more doable
scenarios so the name thing is that well
if i knew the future instances i could
have created a net
that would have been great
but actually the next naive step is that
i don't need to know the future
instances i just kind of need to know
the cumulative distribution in fact i i
really just needed to know what the
final net would have looked like
in fact i don't even need to know the
net if i could generate instances from
that cumulative distribution into the
future then i could sort of think about
a net on those instances and that would
have been a net for my future
this is starting to look more like maybe
we can actually do this
in fact i don't even need to know the
instances or net or distribution another
way to think about it is that
i just need to have a pretty good sense
of what instances i'm going to see let's
say maybe i had a super set of all the
future instances
and this super set wasn't huge like it
kind of it actually
included information about the points i
was going to see in the future
because i i could use this in fact if i
had a super set of instances in the
future i could use it to create some
kind of a pessimistic net
and it would have become more and more
pessimistic the larger the super simple
and that's
really what i care about is
i just care to be able to generate
instances
that look like they would have been the
superset of future instances
what do i mean i really mean that i just
want to be able to generate a bunch of
instances not too many of them and sort
of statistically speaking i could have
imagined a world that they would have
been a superset of the adversary's
points
okay i have weakened
my wishful thinking to the point that is
exactly essentially what we're going to
show
so
to summarize what is it we are trying to
do we are trying to preserve
anti-concentration over a sequence of
smooth distributions
and it's not hard to do it at one round
because each distribution is smooth it's
anti-concentrated really the challenge
is to deal with their correlations
so
this is exactly what we do and
in two works kind of refining this idea
we can think about
coupling an adaptive adversary
with
uh
uniform distributions
so what do i mean
i mean that
there is a joint distribution between
these two worlds one world is the
adversarial world and the other world is
the uniform sarcastic world
where in the adversarial world i'm
taking t instances from whatever that
adaptive adversary did and in the
uniform world i'm getting a little bit
more samples i'm taking t
almost t over sigma number of samples
and importantly with high probability
that whatever the adversary would have
generated would have been a subset of
what i generated from the uniform
distribution
so this is true
you can prove this with rejection
sampling i'm not going to prove it you
can do it as a take-home exercise
um
but kind of why is this useful
why is this useful
well it's useful because
essentially uniform distribution is like
a gold standard of not being
concentrated
so
if i take a lot of points
um if i want let's say that i want to
say that
these points are the whatever the
adversary created wasn't concentrated
it's sufficient to say that a superset
of them
was not concentrated and if that
superset tends to be a uniform
distribution iid
we know that it's not going to be
concentrated because uniform iid is the
best i can hope for
so this is a high-level idea that we are
going to connect an adaptive smoothed
adversary
to a uniform world and say that an
adaptive smooth adversary cannot be much
worse than the stochastic adversary on a
slightly different timeline
why does this help me if i didn't care
about computation this helps me in
creating the nets
in fact one way to think about it is
that i could just take a net with
respect to the uniform distribution
and this is a reasonably good net
because
i i i don't want the adversary to be
able to put too many points in here out
of the t points
and
guess what i created a super set of
those points and if the superset of them
cannot concentrate then the subset of
that was not going to concentrate
so this is very simple this allows me to
create nets that are actually really
nice
and this is really the the punch line of
how you can get statistically optimal
algorithms
that only depend on the vc dimension and
nicely depend on t and one of our sigma
very high level idea
so
i can create nets it's not that hard to
create nets
but computationally speaking
i don't want to create nets because nets
are expensive that was the whole point
of our conversation
so if it's expensive i must be doing
this implicitly and not explicitly
what are some ideas here
well
i'm going to again maybe think a little
bit more naively
what i know is that
if i knew the future that that thing
that would have never happened
i would have never needed to make a net
there's no reason to make a net because
the future itself is defining my net
essentially implicitly
so
if that's the case intuitively what
you're trying to do here
is to say that
maybe
my hallucinations will create the net
for me
what does that look like
well imagine for a second that i truly
gave you
some points that i promise will include
the future
if you just put that in your erm
the hope hope is going to be
that
this erm is not going to require like
i'm not doing any net computation this
by itself is going to concentrate nicely
now
to be fair
i might not have access to these things
i can only hallucinate something that
would have been coupled with whatever
the adversary creates in the future
and that maybe is okay too
because i can still do this type of a
computation and there would have been a
world so like statistically speaking
that would have included this would have
been a superset of what the adverse
series generates
this is the intuitive idea
if i don't want to have nets and i want
to work with oracles
then
it's okay as long as
what i'm generating and i'm putting into
my future
looks like
statistically could have included could
have been a pessimistic
approximation of my actual future yes
there is something pretty subtle here
that that's going on here because if i
had just more random data from uniform
distribution i would wash out my data so
it's like i can't really
just like yeah so i can tell you two
things that's happening here so
let's go here because that would have
happened here as well
um if i have so much data
it's not just washing out that's gonna
happen is that i'm going to have a much
more pessimistic view of this
approximation because
t over sigma is entering it's like
like the regret is getting worse the
longer the sequences get so that's one
aspect of it
the other aspect is something i'm not
going to talk about on the slide but i'm
going to tell you here
which is that generally speaking when
you introduce noise um
two things is happening you're
stabilizing what your algorithm is doing
as in it's not like radically changing
from one step to the next
but you're sort of adding a lot of
regularization that's taking it farther
and farther and you need to
kind of nicely balance these two
i'll i have one more slide that has
epsilon more mathematical intuition and
i'll talk about that again there
any other questions i know that this is
quite high level okay
that's a great question
that's that's another okay that's that's
another great way of thinking about this
is that i'm being more naive than i need
to be
in particular um
this sequence that i'm creating should
really depend on how many more steps i
have left right so you could think about
this as your t minus t capital t minus
little t and that's true as you get
closer to the end you should shrink the
number of stochastic things that you're
creating okay so
i am
heavily simplifying the actual algorithm
because the actual algorithm also
makes some other noise here okay
is the goal of this household
hallucination to be unpredictable or to
regularize or both
depends on what you think about the
future
if i know the future i don't need to
create any more unpredictability about
the future
so the goal of this is to capture
something about the future
but when the future is completely
adversarial
it's essentially the only thing it can
do is to be completely random and
completely unpredictable
okay
but the intuition for why you want to
regularize it's more about why you wish
that you knew what the future is going
to look like
it is it isn't it is regularization it's
just it's it's a different perspective
if the future was fixed
it would have been a different service
one more question and then i'll continue
i don't know who is first
i think it's ready to give you two
questions but like as you approach more
than precise setting you are having to
create exponentially large number of
observations for the erm and the
synthetic
oh uh
i
the regret will depend on the one of our
stigmas oh you cannot cheat there is no
there is no way you're going to yeah
okay i want to give this mathematical
explanation even though i have only can
i take more
can i take five
okay
okay there was a lot of questions okay
and i think
this is actually interesting here um
so what are we saying here i said that
i'm what i just i just want to tell you
that this is kind of believable without
giving you mathematical reasoning for
this
what happened i essentially use the
coupling to turn t interactions with an
adversary to t over sigma interactions
with a uniform distribution
and the idea is that if regret just got
worse and worse the longer the sequence
or the bigger the sequence became
superset i mean longer this super sets
away
then i kind of have already really
proved this by saying that the regret
would have become only worse by
increasing this the sequence and this
sequence would have a regret that is at
most this much
the issue is that regret is technically
speaking not
exactly monotone
it there's something else that's
actually monotone
and
that is something called essentially
rather marker complexity i'm not going
to say what it is but it's a proxy offer
and lower bound for regret and that is
monotone for
in this set so the more you have the
worse it becomes
there's a second issue which is that
again these ais are only kind of
stochastically including
these dis
and
again this there's a resolution here
which is that just because as
constructing the nets didn't really care
about instances care about distribution
something very similar is happening both
rather marker complexity and this
reasoning doesn't really care about
instances they care about stochasticity
is it classical complexity or the
sequential
it's interesting it is classical but
it's regularized and if i were to give
you just because you're one of the
experts to give you why what's happening
here is that we are using a classical
rather marker complexity regularized by
the past as an admissible
um
relaxation of the future
with these uniforms
that might have been things that didn't
make sense to everyone but
what are the regret results and that's
what i mean that you cannot cheat the
regret the result i gave you
has a one over sigma dependence kind of
depends whether it's a binary
classification or not
a little bit and the main reason that it
matters if it's binary or not is that
how i define smoothness if i define
smoothness over the whole set is
slightly different just because i didn't
i'm not necessarily saying that
the label smooth it then if i allowed
sort of
real values here there's no chance zt is
smoother so it's mostly because of these
technical ways of defining it you can
really believe that the binary one is
the correct one to think about i'm going
to skip this there is an interesting way
of improving
to get this square root of one over
sigma and
i'm not able to tell you
but i hope that we can allocate a
whiteboard deep discussion to it and i
will volunteer my graduate students to
read it because it's an interesting way
of thinking about modified way of
thinking about generalization
lastly i do want to say that
there is still a gap statistically
speaking you could have done this
logarithmically
so really what we did here was that we
wanted to
be robust sort of t interactions within
beyond worst case adversary and both the
classical algorithms and analysis both
in terms of oracles and nets
statistically and computationally came
together to help us do this and this is
really the beauty of smooth analysis
that you can really
get rid of the worst part of an
adversary
and
bring it back to the stochastic world
but make all of those results much more
robust so they don't need exact
stochasticity they can essentially work
in the adversarial world except when the
adversary is a little bit more
reasonable
okay i'll end here
thank you for being here and for the
questions
okay thanks
yes